So can we, can we talk about myth and religion a little bit? I mean,
can we start at the beginning, which is like, myths,
how are they born? There's this collective intelligence amongst us human beings.
And we seem to create these beautiful ideas that captivate the minds of
millions. How's such a myth born.
Great question. Okay. So that brings us to terminology again,
in, um, in my field, we, we definitely, I think,
try not to distinguish between religion. I, this is going to be controversial,
I think between religion and myth,
because we call other cultures,
religions myths, right. And then we call our myths religions.
And I guess myth has a bad connotation to it that it's not somehow real. Yeah.
Now what's interesting is that, um,
people like Plato who lived thousands of years ago, 2,500 about,
um, basically made this distinction himself within his own culture,
which was Greek. Right?
So Plato is a very famous Greek philosopher and he would say things like this,
he would say that, um,
he would make a distinction between the reality of the one God
or the one he would call it. He didn't call, use the word God,
but he's referencing a divinity of okay.
And he believes in the soul. Okay. So,
but he would also say that the gods and goddesses of the Greeks are just
myths. So even he would make that distinction again, you know,
he would say the population is not too bright.
So they believe in these gods and goddesses,
but he himself is talking to his students and he's basically talking about
forms, you know? So you know, that live in,
seem to live in these other dimensions. Like this table,
let's go back to this table that we're talking, um, around right now,
he would say that this table is the instantiation of the form of table.
And that there's this table that actually exists somewhere.
It's where this place where numbers exist, like the number two. Okay.
So there we use the number two mathematically, therefore it exists,
but have you ever seen a real one? Have you ever seen the real to know? Okay.
So, but where does it exist? So he says that tables.
So he was also talking about things that, you know,
he says are real making a distinction between the
people. And by the way,
he got this from Socrates's his mentor who was killed by Athens,
because he would say such things, people don't like to be told that they,
what they believe in is not real. Right. Yeah.
By the way, his idea of the forms is just, you just make me realize how,
like incredible was that somebody like that was able to come up with that.
I mean, that idea became a myth that, uh, the idea of forms, right.
That permeated, uh,
probably the most influential set of ideas in, in,
in the history of philosophy and the history of ideas. Yes.
Yeah. He played her, we know him for a reason. Right?
Yeah. So let's say that we're not a,
it's a gray area between religious and myths and maybe not even. Yeah.
Uh, so what,
how's that idea with like little Play-Doh start and permeate the roll-ups.
Oh, how does it happen? Okay. So there are different ways that religions work.
Um, so a lot of people would call the UFO narrative today, like, uh, uh,
and this is what I talk about in my book, like a myth, right. The UFO myth,
but a lot of people believe in it. Okay. So how do these things work? Well,
what I did was I took, um, there's a,
[inaudible] at, um, UC Santa Barbara.
She's a pretty well-known academic who studies religion.
And she has this building block definition of religion, like it builds. Okay.
And so she says, there are, there are,
there are no religious experiences or mythic experiences.
There are experiences.
And then they get interpreted as religious or mythic. Okay.
And so I, I use that with the UFO narrative.
So I take, um, and I compare it to the religious narrative.
So basically what happens, um, what happens is this,
is that a person generally has a very intense experience. Um,
it could be with something that they see in the sky, uh, being, you know,
that they see, um, you know,
like Moses in the burning Bush or something like that,
they tell other people okay.
And there's other people believe them because they say that guy let's take you.
Okay, Lex. Okay. So you're playing, you know, some of your music,
Jimmy Hendrix shows up out of the blue.
So Jimmy Hendricks who's who does electric church stuff. Right.
The electric church movement. So he shows up.
I was sorry for a small tangent. I was, I'm not aware of,
I apologize if I should be, I'm just know how to play all of the songs,
uh, electric church. Is this a thing I know this is a thing.
Yeah. So that was like a philosophy of his or what?
Yes, yes. Yes. So he thought he was, it was like a mission for him, like a, me,
like he was a missionary and he was like doing the electric church.
It was through his mission of music that he was actually impacting people
spiritually. And I think you have to agree that his music is really spirited.
Wow. That's so cool to know that there's like a philosophy there.
I wonder if he's ever written anything. He's spoken about it many times.
Interesting. To actually do some, some research here. Wow.
As another level of depth. That's awesome. Okay. So.
Okay. So say Lex is playing one of his songs,
songs he.
Shows up.
Oh, that's a hard one. I like castles in the sand. It's a sad one,
but I like it.
So I'm playing something.
And all of a sudden, boom, just like Elvis does for people. Yeah.
Hendricks shows up. All right.
And then you're amazed and they just tells you something that's very,
very significant. And he says, you need to tell other people this. Okay.
So then like, okay. Yes. And you start.
And because people believe you and because you are a person of, um,
you know, credibility, people believe you.
And so all of a sudden a movement starts, okay. And it's the Hendrix movement.
It's Hendrix too, or something like that. You know, we call it something, uh,
the next iteration of Hendrix, right. Hendrix lives.
But he lives is this vibration. And only Lex can like, you know, can,
can manifest this vibration. Okay. So like, this is,
this is how religion is Starbucks, you know,
excuse your audience who are religious. I'm actually a practicing Catholic.
So this is how religion starts. They start with first off a contact experience.
Uh, not, I mean, not all of them, but a good portion of them. Um,
P some person has an experience that's transcendent sacred to them and they
go and they tell other people,
and then those people tell other people and then something gets written about
it. Okay. And then it becomes, because it's a charismatic movement.
People become effected by it. And if, if too many people are affected by it,
um, an institution steps in and tries to control the narrative. Uh,
so this is what you'd call the beginning of a religion or a myth,
a very powerful myth. And so it's almost like a star, right? A star is born.
When you say institution,
do you mean some other organization that's already powerful,
doesn't want to become, uh, overpowered by this new movement.
It's usually governments.
Usually. Yeah. So, uh, I have a couple of examples.
I use the example of the Christian Church in my book,
because I'm most familiar with the history of Christianity and, you know,
Christianity was started by this Jewish man.
And it was a movement that, you know, he was a very powerful,
charismatic person. Other people believed in him.
And then his followers talked about him. And then other than, you know,
usually early Christians before the
three hundreds were generally people who were disenfranchised because he had a
pretty radical idea that, you know, humans should have dignity.
And this was pretty radical during that time.
So women who didn't have dignity and, you know,
slaves who didn't have dignity at the time, um,
converted Christianity in droves. And so what happened was that all of a sudden,
um, it became this belief system that was undercurrent. And then, uh,
Constantine, um, who was an elite, uh,
had an experience and made Christianity to state religion. Um,
by that time there were different forms of Christianity,
probably hundreds of them, well,
most likely and Constantine and the people who
were powerful with him decided that their idea,
this is the council of Nicea decided that there was one form and they call it
universal. So the one form of Christianity and this should be it. And so they,
they kind of took out all the other denominations of Christianity and different
forms of it. So you can see that a very,
very powerful set of beliefs put a
culture on fire. Right. And so how did they,
they had to deal with that fire somehow. And so they narrativized, it,
they decided how do we interpret this? And they interpreted it as they wished,
but that wasn't the only interpretation of Christianity. I have another example,
um, in the Catholic church, um, a lot of times,
and I'm going to use the example of, uh, foul Stina. Um,
she's, um, she's a nun and she's Polish. And, um,
I think it was in the early 20th century, if not the 18 hundreds,
that she had a very powerful, uh, many experiences actually of,
of Jesus. And she saw Jesus with rays coming out of his,
his heart. And basically she called this, his divine mercy,
and it became a devotion in Poland and it spread the Catholic church was
not, not into this at all. Okay.
And so they did everything they could to try to suppress Faustino's influence,
which was growing and growing and growing and growing. Okay.
And so they were very successful in trying to keep her quiet and she died. Okay.
Years later, John Paul,
the second Polish sainted her and created
the divine mercy devotion,
which is worldwide now and millions and millions of people.
But do you see how they, they, you know, completely controlled.
So fascinating that it, uh, that it just starts with a single suit. Like I said,
contact experience, experiences, the keyword,
and D is your sense that those experiences are
legitimate. So it's not artificially constructed.
For the most part. There are legitimate experiences that people have.
Why would someone want to put themselves through what they go through? Like,
why would Jesus want to get crucified? I mean, that's a pretty nasty way to die.
Um, you know, why would, [inaudible] bring this upon herself? Um,
the people that I meet who've said that they've seen you a frozen,
that most of them don't want to be known because of the ridicule that goes along
with it. So I honestly think that, you know,
there are people who are maybe not stable and we'd like the attention,
but for the most part, normal people don't want this attention.